Your next big goal in this course is to recreate a visualization to improve it.
In order to do that, I'm going to be teaching you some design principles that
can enhance your graphics and help you prototype.
>> I'll also take you through how to refine a design, and
also a few metrics that'll help you measure their effectiveness.
>> We'll be seeing all the different options we have for choosing a chart or
a graphic depending on our data.
And learn some of the formalism and
theory surrounding how to make that selection.
We'll also be building a much more complicated graphic,
using a library built upon D3, and see how we can engage our audience more.
Let's go learn about charts now.